hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
discovery of a druggable pocket in sars
co v2 spike
new avenue to defeat the covid19
this webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event
series and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented to you by
lab roots and sponsored by jen script
for more information
about gen script go to www.jenscript.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that ask a question box
to the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing
education credits tab located on the top
right hand corner of your presentation
window and follow the process
to obtain those credits without further
ado i now present
today's speaker excuse me dr emery
berger
founder and managing director of the max
planck
bristol center for minimal biology for a
complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr berger
welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
hello my name is emre berger i'm the
director of the max planck
bristol center at the university of
bristol uk
and i'm delighted to give this webinar
today about our discovery of a draggable
pocket
in this ask of two spike protein and to
discuss with you a new finding which we
think is an avenue to defeat the current
kovit 19
crisis it is a bit unusual for me to
give this presentation
like this but this kind of remote
e-presentation appears to be
the new normal so we should try to enjoy
this
i don't think i need to say a lot about
the
crisis which is currently raking
havoc all around the globe we have this
virus
it's the south corona virus ii a new
form of disaster coronavirus
which has spread all over the world
starting from wuhan
and it has led to major disruption
everywhere it is has cost countless
lives and uh
it is an economic pain and we do not yet
know how to get
out of uh this crisis and
uh what you see here on the left side is
uh does ask of two it's the coronavirus
which causes
the covid 19 disease and
what you see there is basically a ball
shaped structure and with
spikes coming out of it and this is the
spike glycoprotein which also gives the
coronavirus its name because these
spikes which are protruding from the
surface of the corona virus they look
like little crowns and
uh one of the things which we have done
here in bristol
during the lockdown phase of the crisis
when we
like many others uh started to work on
coronavirus to try to contribute to do
something about
the pandemic is to determine the
structure of
this spike glycoprotein primer which you
would normally find on the surface of
the coronavirus
biotechnology which we use which is
called cryo
electron microscopy and by doing so we
made a discovery which might help us
to address the current crisis let me
explain why we actually
uh entered this coronavirus research
what happened here in bristol was that
uh
when the crisis became
more problematic many things almost
everything that was not essential was
shutting down including the
including the university by but at the
same time
there are expert scientists here in
bristol and also
elsewhere clinicians and vaccine
people and also coronavirus researchers
who would spontaneously self-organize to
form
groups of scientists who continued to
work
to investigate what this uh
pandemic was about to look at the virus
itself but
also to develop testing methods so that
one could locally test the population
and to see who had actually
coronavirus who had this like covet 19
and who didn't
and for this they require antigens
antigens are the proteins which
are parts of the corona virus and my
laboratory i'm a synthetic biologist and
a structural biologist
is particularly good at making proteins
so my laboratory was tasked to form a
core team
during the lockdown to produce uh
antigens and one of the major antigens
so those are
those proteins which the immune system
will then recognize when something
foreign comes in and make
antibodies against it is exactly this
spike protein which is a trimer of three
glycoproteins and it's called
s so what you see on the right side is
the structure which we determined as a
quality control
of the material which we were producing
for the clinicians and for the serology
people who were building up their tests
we wanted to see whether
the protein which we were making was
similar to what you would find
on the surface of the corona virus and
you can see
on the right the cryoelectron microscopy
density so this is what we get out of
our cryoelectron microscope when we look
at
the spike protein which we
produced and you already see that it's
like a trimer so you have one blue
protein and a magenta protein and a
green protein and they look identical
and they form this timer which is the
spike
protein so how does cryoelectron
microscopy
work so basically what you do is you
take a solution of the sample which you
have produced in our case the
spike protein from the saskof2
virus and then this solution you plunge
free so you make vitreous eyes out of it
so that
doesn't uh that you basically get a
snapshot of what is
in solution when you plunge freeze it
and this
frozen vitreous eyes with your samples
and that goes into the cryoelectron
microscope
now all of us know how electron
microscopy works probably
because we have seen these pictures of
cells like black and white
showing like the structures within cells
so this was how electron microscopy was
done
years ago in the last few years electron
microscopy has made an
incredible advance and now you can
actually get not only those rough
structures
of what is in a cell but you can
actually get atomic structures
of proteins and protein complexes by
applying this flash frozen or planche
frozen cryo electron microscopy
technique and we have like a center here
in bristol which is headed by christiane
schafitzer
and they are outstanding cryo-electron
microscopy so when we produced our
spike proteins for the zerologists and
for the other scientists who were
looking at this new disease we then also
use the cryoelectron microscope to see
what the structure of the proteins
which we made well that's important
because you have to have the same
structure which is also on the virus so
that you can then confidently
apply this for serology testing and when
we determine the
structure and that you do by assigning
the material which comes out
that density which comes out of the
cryoelectron microscope and tracing
the amino acids of your protein through
it we found
additional density so we could assign
everything but then there was still
density left in our structure and we
were very surprised by this you see this
here on the
bottom right so in the blue uh
this drawing which represents one of the
spike protein monomers there was this
extra tube of density there which did
not make sense and which we could not
explain
by what we knew about the spike protein
also from
other structures which other people have
solved before so
we saw that we had some extra density
there and we did not know what this was
and the processing and the cryo-em data
collection was done by satish and ufo
and what you do when you have a trimeric
protein that you and which
is kind of like where all three strains
are identical you
determine the structure first in an
unsymmetrized form so they'll be reached
roughly three angstrom resolution so we
could see details
three angstrom apart and then you apply
a symmetrization where you then treat
all of them equally and that
improves the data you have and we could
go to 2.8 extreme resolution and that's
quite high resolution value
know what you see is real so we had this
extra density in there
and we knew that it was real but we
didn't know
what it was then so
what we did there then is first we asked
ourselves that okay we have three of
these
uh individual monomers in the trimer do
all three of them contain this extra
density
so we looked at the unsymmetrized
structure so we made one step back
looked at the blue chain at the magenta
chain at the green chain and yes in
all three of them we had this extra
density which looked like a tube
within the spike protein monomers
so all three sides all three of these
pockets which we have seen
with this extra density were occupied by
this extra density
we just didn't know what it was and as
you can see at the bottom here on the on
the left in this
four pictures you see electron density
all over
the amino acids also forming the pocket
in which this extra density was so that
you see that the quality was really good
so you could put in the individual amino
acids
and then you had this extra density so
now we had to figure out what this
actually
was and this work was done by christine
and together with carpe
built the model into the electron
density
data and what christine did was she had
a look and she
looked at this tube which we had in
there like this unassigned extra
electron electron microscope density
and she asked in this wonderful resource
which we have which is the protein data
bank
do we see in some other structures which
have been solved previously
similar tubes of density which look kind
of like what we had
and so she had a look there she compared
many many structures which she found
like
literally thousands of structures or
tens of thousands which are in the
protein data bank and
she found several proteins including
this fatty acid kinase
b3 which i showed and also this odorant
binding protein
which also had a very similar shaped
tube
in the proteins and where people
know knew what it was so they had
assigned it properly and it looked like
it is a fatty acid and more precisely it
looked like based on space
and and the shape considerations and the
available
uh room in in this pocket that it uh and
also like how they
this extra density curved in this pocket
that it might be
linoleic acid or linoleic acid is a
fatty acid which occurs
in our bodies and it looked like what we
had
is actually linoleic acid based on these
considerations
so we had this feeling that okay we have
in the spike protein from the
zarskov to virus we have extra density
in there and this extra density seems to
be coming from
a fatty acid which is bound and this
fatty acid
apparently could be linoleic acid so we
had to nail it down of course and ask
ourselves what
was it really linoleic acid and what you
see here on this slide is
again the spike protein uh in the side
view and now also in a top
view and you see now this extra density
which is in this
red uh box in there which we know
assigned as a linoleic acid but at this
time it was just a proposal so we need
to find
a way how to really nail it down that it
is linoleic
acid and i i remember that it was locked
down time so like occasionally i was at
home and you couldn't really
do much except for working in the
laboratory or being at home and then
play
badminton in the garden and i was just
moaning around about
how can i find out whether this
extra molecule which we have in the
spike protein is really linoleic acid
and i was playing with
uh cristiano chaffetzel actually who not
only is a fantastic electron
microscopist but also happens to be
my wife and uh she then said that why
don't you call oscar
so oscar is off kashtava and he's a
collaborator of us in the max plant
bristol center he works in uh
in the max planck institute in
heidelberg and he's a lipid
expel so he knows how to operate a mass
spectral uh meter which can then detect
lipids which are bound
to our proteins this is in joachim
schwartz's group so johannesburg is a
max plant director who is the uh the pi
of oscar so i did call oscar and they
said oscar we have a protein you know a
very interesting protein and we
think that we have a lipid or like a
fatty acid in there could you
look at it for us and find out what it
is and oscar said just send it
so we sent him the sample and he put it
into
the extremely uh well-equipped
mass spectroscopy the facility
and he could then find out what this
extra density was and yes indeed it was
a fatty acid and yes indeed it was
linoleic
acid which you know by looking at the
mass which he got out of the
mass spectrometer and compare it to the
chemical mass which you get from the
chemical structure of the molecule so we
had
linoleic acid in there the mass was
consistent
with it it is an ionization experiment
so you need to take the mass of one
proton away from the
calculated mass and up to the fourth
position after the decimal
the mass was exactly consistent with
linoleic acid so now we are more
confident that yes
indeed this extra molecule which we have
discovered in the spike protein
is a fatty acid and it is linoleic acid
as the mass spectral
metric data had confirmed so now we
could really look back
again at the structure we determined
and this pocket which we saw in there
and you see it now like you know
magnification on the right side on this
slide
so what we found was a fatty acid
binding pocket specific for linoleic
acid
and interestingly and you see this on
the in the drawing
it was bipartite so we had like this
kind of greasy tube
about the hydrocarbon tail of the fatty
acid was ticking in so that's like
fatty acids like linoleic does it have a
hydrocarbon tail which is hydrophobic
and they have a polar head group which
is hydrophilic and interacts then with
positively charged
amino acids or with hydrogen bondo so we
have like this
greasy part and this was sticking into
in a greasy
tube in one of the spike
monomers which is shown here in green
and then we had this
other part which was kind of like the
polar lid
interacting with the polar head group of
the linoleic acid and that you see here
in green so there were actually two of
the monomers involved and not just any
part
of the monomers but a very special part
of the spike protein
is where this pocket is in the it's that
part which is the so-called receptor
binding domain
so that domain which then attaches to a
protein as we will see in a moment on
the surface of cells
then and leads to the infection and to
the disease
then you get unlucky but apart from that
just based on like structural
considerations when we looked at this
pocket and you see this now
at the bottom in a 3d representation
showing the surface charge and the
hydrophobicity pattern
in this pocket so this is the kind of
uh pockets which people who are in drug
discovery really
like because it's a pocket which very
smugly fits around this
you know like i said so you can design a
different small
molecule which fits in there and will
possibly displace
this linoleic acid and that is very very
important as you will see
in a moment and when we had all this
data together
we wrote this up and this is also the
reason for this talk for the invitation
by
uh genescript to give this webinar so we
wrote this uh manuscript together we
found an
unexpected free fatty acid binding
pocket in the cryovm structure of this
ask koftu
spike protein and the manuscript is
currently under review and available as
a pre-print
on bio archives because during this
crisis more than
any time else wonder shares all the data
one has to
inspire other people to find possibly
ways to deal with
the covid19 disease or with the virus
and that's why you deposit
your new findings on this freely
accessible public
preprint server which is bio archives
all right so here we were and
we had discovered this binding pocket
and the binding pocket was b part time
so very interesting
different than normally because normally
like linoleic acid binding proteins
would contain the lid and the greasy
tube in one
protein but we are here we had two
proteins contributing to this so this
was all very interesting but
you know as a structured biologist and
generally as a scientist you have to
always be very
careful whether that what you see there
is real and whether
if you see something which nobody else
had seen before whether
you are still dealing with a protein
which is actually functional and you
didn't introduce something in the
due to your experiment which doesn't
represent reality so we needed to find
out whether the spike protein with this
linoleic acid bond
which we had discovered whether this
would be still functional and this was
now again an issue that how do you do
this
so during this crisis what really
impressed me was that
you know the problems are coming but the
solutions are also coming very quickly
after each other so not like two or
three months normally as it would take
but
you have a problem but the solution
comes like somehow also very very
fast and so when we had this situation
that we needed to
check the functionality of this spike
protein which we had made
and we didn't know exactly how then my
good friend tero
from genescript i remember this he wrote
me an email in the middle of the night
roughly around midnight where he had
said that like they came across like a
new
uh surrogate virus neutralization essay
which sort of
allows you to test samples and also
serum and antibodies and
whatever you have which might uh they'll
be relevant to
uh kovid and tozaskov2 which can let you
test this in your laboratory in a normal
laboratory safety environments where you
don't have to work with
tissue where you don't have to work with
human samples and you end with
live virus even and go then into the
category 2 and category 3
which we didn't have any access to so
when i was thinking about
like how can i show the functionality of
the spy protein we made then we got this
uh email from tearow providing the
solution and it was the sarrogate uh
virus neutralization kit which is now
called c-pass smart kit i think in
genescript
and it works very cleverly so how this
works is that
normally on the human cells you would
have this uh receptor which the
virus binds to with the coronavirus and
it comes in and that's called ace2 so
it's like a protein called ace2 that
sits on the surface of the cells
so in this essay
what they did was to deposit the same
protein
ace2 on a microtiter plate on the
surface so now you have the s2 sitting
as it would normally sit on the surface
of the cell
it's sitting as i have it sitting on a
microphoto plate
and added a piece of the spike protein
exactly this receptor binding domain
and put a color reagent on it that's
called horseradish peroxidase so when
you add a chemical it produces a color
so what happens now is that if you add
this this rbd this receptor binding
domain this isolated recombinant
receptor binding domain with that color
reagent on
to your plate then it will bind to the
ac2 and it will produce a color
now when you titrate in either virus
or spike protein or serum from patients
into this reaction you will displace the
rbds which are bounded and you will
reduce the color so you will know that
your material is functional
because it still binds ace to by looking
at a
color disappearing in the same that's
exactly what we did
so we could show that our spike protein
with the la bond would
very competently compete away the rbd
with the hrp and we would lose the color
and we could even determine
how well our spike protein bound to
ace2 so now we knew that it was
functional and we
also confirmed this by a size exclusion
chromatogram
uh where we mixed the a2 protein and the
spike protein and then ran it over
column and so that they were coming out
together so we knew now
that the spike protein with the la in
there was functional
as people had described before when they
didn't know that it had
la bound and it would bind ace 2 and how
this works is you see on a model
on the right so we have in blue again
this receptor binding domain of the
spike protein
now with our la's sitting there in the
pocket in a red i have colored the
amino acids which are involved in the
binding of phase 2
is showing here in a yellow and you see
that there's a very tight complex
between this red part which is called
achilles heel because that's the
sensitive part of the spike protein
which it needs to
react with the cellular ac2 receptor to
get into the cells that is bound by
ace two and uh this is how this works
and our material was
functional so thank you so much tyro for
helping out uh
us out in there by providing early
access to a better version
of the kit which you were putting
together
so we now knew that our material had
la in there and that it was functional
so spike protein was functional so now
we could ask ourselves what are the
structural features that define this la
binding and we could find four features
which i show here
so one is that we have this greasy tube
into which the
hydrocarbon tail of the linoleic as it
fits in there
and we have at the beginning of this uh
greasy tube we have a gating helix so
that's like a helix which needs to move
away so that the la can
penetrate into that and this we could
find out by comparing the apo structures
people have determined before when they
didn't know yet that it was late binding
and our structure with the la binding
itself and superimposing them
so we saw the gating helix the gating
helix has
a big aromatic residues like tyrosines
which swing open like a door when
you're pushing the gating helix away and
then the linoleic acid can then
penetrate into this
greasy tube we also have a polar lid as
i said before coming from the next
receptor binding domain and that has
consequences because you have like this
next receptor binding domain which shuts
the
uh the lid on the linoleic i said when
it has penetrated into there by
interacting with the polar head group of
the fatty acid
and this brings the rbds together so
what you have there you have a situation
and this will become very important that
the receptor binding domains which
normally would be loosely attached and
with space in between them
are coming close together and end up in
a condensed form so those are the four
architectural features which define la
binding by the coronavirus spike
protein and now we could of course ask
ourselves said how conserved are those
features
there are currently seven corona viruses
which we know four of them are
circulating they are like harmless
coronaviruses they have jumped from
enemies already earlier
over to us in humans and they are the
common chords they are not
liter and we have three very little
uh coronaviruses that's the current
source of two which causes
uh covid19 but we had of course before
like 15 years ago also
the original south corona virus which
was extremely lethal but not that
infectious
as what we had i have now and we had
also
the mouse like the middle uh eastern
respiratory syndrome coronavirus which
is
also very related but was luckily also
not that infectious so we could now have
a look
and ask is this fatty acid binding
pocket conserved and
is this linoleic acid binding maybe
somehow an element of pathology of the
viruses
and uh to cut a long story short what we
found is that
exactly those elements which we found in
saskatoon are conserved in south korff
so
very lethal other coronavirus and
even saw the mouse cough has uh
separated thousands of years ago from
sounds and this
in the middle east and not in china
where the uh south corona virus comes
from
it also has the features of which we
have seen in zavkov2 so
it could be and it's very possible
that this linoleic acid binding is an
element of pathology
so why are we thinking that that could
be the case so what is so special about
this linoleic acid
so now when we had the data together and
we saw that in the other pathogenic
coronaviruses this linoleic acid binding
pocket is apparently also conserved we
looked very deeply into what is linoleic
acid actually and it turns out you know
like as it is an incredibly exciting
molecule
it is an essential free fatty acid so it
cannot be synthesized in
cells you have to take it up by the diet
and linoleic acid is a
important molecule a precursor for
a metabolic pathway with which the
the body then synthesizes out of this
essential free fatty acid avocadonic
acid
and icosanoids including prostaglandin
and those are molecules which are
central to inflammation
and immune modulation and those are key
symptoms of covid19
so this systemic inflammation everywhere
in the body is what kills people when
they
get the disease and you can already see
that if you
do something like if you sequester this
scavenge this uh linoleic acid out of
this metabolic pathway that you will
have like
detrimental effects on those molecules
which would protect you against
inflammation and immune and other
symptoms of cobalt 19. linoleic acid is
also essential for men
and maintaining membrane fluidity
because it's an unsaturated fatty acid
and that's what makes your membranes of
your cells fluid
and this again is important for the
surface tension in lungs where
the air has to penetrate through the
membrane into the cell so that it can
the oxygen can be taken
up and it has been shown in different
diseases before that if you
mess with the linoleic acid acid pathway
lipid composition
it will lead to acute respiratory
distress syndrome
and severe pneumonia which are both
again key elements of covalent 19
pathology and a third aspect which
struck us was that linoleic acid
directly binds to our receptor free
fatty acid receptor which is called ffa
r1 gpr40 and this receptor is a key
regulator and insulin resist
a disease which is central to diabetes
as you all know and diabetes is a risk
factor
for covid19 patients so people who have
diabetes die
much more frequently from the disease
than
people who do not have diabetes so and
they already have an impairment
in the la signaling which is excavated
by
the virus and what uh came as like a
an incredibly interesting finding very
recently was our paper in the cell
where people described the lipidomic and
proteomic
uh situation in this era of covet 19
patients and you can see there that
the la levels are continuously
decreased so all together if you not
take this together and digest it
then you realize that our discovery
provides the first direct structural
link between linoleic
acid covid19 pathology
and this ask of two virus itself
because the spike protein binds directly
to this linoleic acid which is so
central to all these processes
which have repercussions on disease
development
in covid19 and our results suggest that
both the
la binding pocket within the s-protein
and the multi-nodal la signaling axis
involved in
all kinds of metabolic pathways and
inflammation and immune
modulation represent excellent
therapeutic intervention points
against soft cop2 infections
particularly in patient groups
which have increased risk due to
metabolic preconditions like people
who have diabetes
so this is our discovery so now okay
so we have this pocket we have linoleic
acid in there we know that it's like
potentially an element of pathology
it is conserved in zarskoff and also in
a mousekov
so what can we do about this is there
like a technical way to not proceed and
use this information which we have
to develop a
approach to defeat covet 19.
so let me now come back again to the
spike protein itself so i told you that
when we have cryo-em
we have a snapshot of what is in
solution and
when you look at what you have on the
cryogen grid you can look at the
individual molecules
and you see that the
spike protein exists in two forms so
there is this open form which you see
here on the left
where you can see that this blue protein
the receptor binding domain is ticking
out
and in red again we see the achilles
heel domain
and this is ready to engage with the ac2
receptor and then to penetrate into the
cells and trigger those events
which cause the infection and the
disease if you are
unlucky so this form is called the open
form
the which is competent in receptor
binding which is the infectious form
on the other hand you have this closed
form so in this closed form
this receptor binding domains all three
are tuckered in as you can see here
and these red achilles heal domains are
hidden
and cloaked away so why does the virus
do this so this is a closed
form here in this closed form the
achilles heel domain
of the receptor binding part is hidden
and this form is not infectious because
it cannot bind the receptor and why does
the virus do this
this is a way of avoiding the immune
surveillance so when the virus comes
into the body it has to
avoid being targeted by antibodies which
the
body produces which would eliminate
infectivity
so often it hides it tries to hide that
critical part of the achilles heel
with which it would bind the receptor
but it has to swing out
sufficiently often that when an ace ii
receptor is there it can latch onto it
and it can get into the cells and
cause infection so what you have is a
dynamic equilibrium
you have the open form you have the
closed form the open form
is ace to competent binding competent
and it's infectious
the clause form cannot bind the receptor
so it's not
infections and now what we saw when we
looked at that is that in our case when
we
just counted the number of open and
closed forms on the
grid so on this in the snapshot of what
was in solution we had 30 percent of the
uh spike proteins there in the open form
and a 70 percent so like the majority
was in the close one so
in our case the uh not infectious form
was preponder preponderance
in the structures which were determined
before which didn't have l.a bound where
people did not
have la in there the open form so the
infectious form was dominating so you
had more of the infectious form and less
of the of the closed non-infectious form
so this already told us that
that you can influence the
the relative amounts of infectious virus
and non-infectious virus
for example by la and how does this work
so when we now look in a schematic
representation i'm trying to show this
now schematically
we have in the middle we have the
structure with the three
linoleic acids in there and again like
blue and green and
magenta are the three individual spike
proteins and on the left i have shown
you
how the apo from without la looks like
the uh
by looking at the structures which
people have done
before so you have this loosely arranged
uh receptor binding domains and you have
these canyons
in between so you can imagine how these
can like quite nicely swing out
and then contact the s2 receptor in our
case however
the la because it binds two rbds at the
same time acts as a staples which is
tuckering down the uh the receptor
binding domains and they have a harder
time to swindle
so it's not completely gone yet but the
equilibrium is shifted
towards the non-infectious form because
the la sits there
and it tuckers the two uh
two rbds each together and it makes this
closed
locked down form which we observed in
our structure
could this be used to develop now
something an approach
an antiviral which would always keep the
spike protein and the locked
conformation so we looked in the
literature and yes there is a precedent
for this
it was done by michael rossmann himself
with a titan in
structural virology and he was drugging
rhinovirus and defeating rhinovirus
using exactly the same concept
which we are now proposing for the sask
of two
coronavirus which causes corbit 19. so
rhinovirus causes the common cause so
it's
not such a major disease but still for
people who have asthma very dangerous
so what they found is that in the
rhinovirus you have like
these viral proteins which are shown
schematically here in blue
you have a canyon between them again and
you have a pocket where an unidentified
fatty acid bonds so they couldn't
identify it but normally there would be
a fatty acid binding in there
so what they now developed are drugs
which
displace the fatty acid go in there
and then lock this
viral protein in a form which can no
longer be recognized by the receptor
so the receptor has to be the receptor
as you can see on the left
binds a very defined structure which is
caused by the
fatty acid binding the antiviral protein
sitting on top of it
and then you know put a bulky uh
chemical in there which binds better to
that pocket than the fatty acid
and you distort this
uh uh this viral protein and you
sterically block it in a form
that it cannot bind the receptor anymore
then you
abolish infectivity and this was exactly
what happened with driving virus so
based on this
you know developed small molecules and
two of them are currently
in the clinic also as inhale
label molecules and it's a successful
drug development to shut down the
infectivity
of corona virus so what do we now want
to do i think it's
entirely obvious so we have already
learned that without
linoleic acid we have the majority of
the proteins
uh the disaster cof2 s proteins in the
open form which is infectious compounded
when we add linoleic acid then we shift
the equilibrium towards
a form which is closed predominantly and
less infectious now if we can develop a
lycras mended a super linoleic acid
mimic antiviral which would always shut
down
there's a spike protein in the closed
conformation we could
eliminate vascoph2 infectivity
and therefore shuts the
virus down before it even enters the
cells and this is what we would like to
do
now so let me recap our finding so we
found a linoleic acid binding
pocket in softcuff to spike and define
the characteristics of it at near atomic
resolution by cryo-electron microscopy
we found based on structural
considerations that this is likely
conserved
in a highly pathogenic stars cause the
original stars
virus and mask of coronaviruses the
pocket is bipartite so it connects
two receptor binding domains each within
the s primer
it stabilizes upon la binding the closed
form of spike
without the rbds locked down and tucked
in
and this closed form is not or less
infectious there is a precedent
rhinovirus as i have shown you which
conveys a small molecule antiviral
strategy
and you have heard a lot of the hype
which is going on now about vaccines
against coronavirus but remember
that in the case of hiv which is another
historic precedent
after 30 years of intensive research we
still do not have an hiv
vaccine and what works are anti-virus or
cocktail of small
molecules which keeps the virus at bay
and
this encourages us because it means that
the same could be possibly done
with sars cough to the virus which
causes
covet 19 disease i want to thank at this
point the great people who
volunteered to do this work because when
the university locked down
then continuous working was only on a
voluntary basis and i had this fantastic
people
who volunteered and who wanted to
continue working to contribute
to do what they could to contribute to
defeat
the crisis or to do something about it
and i of course also thank the
many funders who are funding my lab
because we are using that funds which
we got from demno to do or and fuel our
core with
research i would in particular thank
genescript
and oracle oracle was fantastic they
provided the cloud
computing infrastructure which we needed
to calculate
our cryovm structures and process that
data at the speed
which was required
and i i want to mention where this
work happened it was in the max plan
bristol center it's a fantastic
collaboration between the university of
bristol and the max planck
is air airshaft in germany and this
center was critical to identify linoleic
acid because we had
access to the mass spec
equipment and expertise of our
collaborators at the max blank institute
in heidelberg there is a lot of other
work which i couldn't allude to today
taking place at the max planck center
not only uh
in the context of covet 19 but in the
context of kovite covid19 we are
developing the also
synthetic vaccines we hope that we can
elicit a strong immune response
in case that the vaccines which are
currently being developed
do not work so well and we are also
working on synthetic
mega antibodies as passive immunization
reagents for people who are very sick
and who
cannot make antibodies themselves and
with this i would like to
thank you for your attention and come to
an end
and i think it's obvious what we want to
do now based on our groundbreaking
discovery
we want to develop small molecular
antivirus as michael rossman did
to abolish south cough to infectivity
i thank you for your attention
thank you dr berger for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we have a few questions already coming
in
how long after infection can antibodies
against sars kobe 2 still be detected
in someone's blood
well i mean the data is because it is a
new disease it's not quite
unambiguous yet but it appears to be
that
uh for several months
antibody specific antibodies can be
detected but then it seems that it is
going off
and that is an issue because you have
probably seen that now we are entering a
phase where you have re-infection of
people so people who have
already had the virus a few months ago
at the beginning of the
pandemic now can get re-infected again
even though they did have antibodies
against the virus at some point so it
appears to be that after a few months
the antibodies which one has
is uh are tapering off again so one does
not have a lasting
immunity thank you so much and do the
antibody
levels correlate with the disease
of severity in long-term immunity
could you please repeat the question
again do the antibody
levels correlate with the disease
severity
and long-term immunity
well i mean they do correlate with
long-term immunity if you do not have
antibodies if they are
falling off the titles are falling off
you become vulnerable
again then the other part of the
question whether they correlate to
severity
one cannot really say that because we
don't know enough about the disease yet
it's too new but what we know is that
there are some people
who overcome the disease who recover
from the disease but
don't make any antibodies so there are
defenses then a different way of
defending it's about another mechanism
it's called
t cell defense so that works differently
so you can actually recover from the
disease without producing
any antibodies because the body has
other means
to defend against it but mostly in most
cases
it is done by antibodies and if you lose
those antibodies again over time
you become again vulnerable against
reinfection
sure thank you so much and i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions coming in
is it possible to have two la or la
analog dimers to increase the binding
affinity that's an
excellent question and we are working on
this we do not know yet
but we are thinking about having two or
three laser la mimics
somehow bound together so that we
increase the affinity so exactly yes
this is one of the directions we are
looking into now
thank you so much we have time for one
more question
when we actually have a vaccine dr
berger
how will it be assured that all
individuals have
access to it for example those who are
uninsured
how long will it take to um make it
available to everyone
that is the key question we all all now
thinking about unfortunately i'm not the
right person to answer this
what i do know is that it takes time to
produce
vaccine doses there is not enough glass
wires and syringes
available at the moment to actually have
enough
advice to to vaccinate everybody so this
is also
from the manufacturing perspective an
incredible
challenge you have to have billions of
doses in one of the previous questions
we
uh we asked that what happens after
several months when the
protection because the antibodies are
falling off goes away do we then have to
re-immunize the whole the
world again do we have to vaccinate
every six months everybody in the world
forever protection
against the disease so the answer is it
is an
incredible challenge an unprecedented
challenge
and i can only hope that we will find
ways where
the whole world can work together so
that everybody
who is vulnerable gets the vaccine which
they need
absolutely dr berger this has been an
incredible presentation
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience members before
we go
i can do that yes i'm very happy to do
this so you know
we are this is an incredible and
unprecedented health
crisis and it is incredible how this has
affected all of us
before the covet crisis we would not
have known how fragile
really our society is that something
like this can happen
and then everything goes in a lock down
so during this lockdown when i went to
the lab to
work i was going through an empty city
there was nobody on the streets it was
incredibly
spooky i would not have thought that
something like this could happen and it
was
unimaginable in peace time for me that
something like this can happen but at
the same time i have also seen how
everybody like scientists nurses
people who were delivering food people
who were helping
others who could not leave their house
and relied on
others to help them or everybody rose to
the occasion on
every level so this was also incredibly
encouraging and this makes me
extremely hopeful that if we work
together and if we all do our best and
rise to the occasion
then we will defeat this pandemic and we
will get out of this
again and things will return to normal
and i'm looking forward to this
absolutely dr burger thank you again
for your time today and for your
important research and before we go i
want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
and i also want to thank our sponsor jen
script for
today's webinar questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via
your contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration and this webcast can be
viewed
up to six months till march 2021
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay
safe and stay healthy take care bye
bye